bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag la
planète croule sous les déchets chaque
minute c'est l'équivalent d'un
camion-poubelle de plastique qui est
déversée dans les océans à saint quentin
en yvelines le territoire poursuit une
politique de sensibilisation engagé il
ya plusieurs années
amélioration des collectes renforcement
de réseau de déchetteries lancement du
défi zéro déchet avec l'agencé locale de
l'énergie et du climat
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ces
acteurs qui agissent pour recycler nous
avons également suivi les conseils d'une
saint-quentinoise qui a opté pour un
quotidien sans déchets alors que faire
de nos déchets et comment les réduire
ont fait le point c'est parti
[Musique]
les déchets leur mauvaise gestion
contribuer au changement climatique et à
la pollution atmosphérique le leitmotiv
extraire produire consommer jeter n'est
plus de mise en 2021
le but ultime est désormais de générer
le moins de déchets possible pour le
bien de la planète et de l'humanité
la collecte et la valorisation des
déchets incombe aux communautés de
communes depuis 2016 finie la gestion
commune par commune à saint quentin en
yvelines
toutes les décisions sont prises depuis
l'hôtel d'agglomération
les collectes ont été harmonisés sur les
douze communes du territoire
la loi de transition énergétique de 2015
impose une réduction des déchets d'ici à
on plus de l'intérêt environnemental
s'ajoute un intérêt économique
chaque territoire paient une taxe à
l'état sur la tonne d'ordures ménagères
produites chaque saint quentinois
produits 420 kg de déchets par an moins
que la moyenne des franciliens et que la
moyenne nationale
un rendu que souhaite encore améliorer
l'agglomération en 2020 celle ci a
impulsé une nouvelle politique pour
réduire l'impact lié aux déchets on peut
pas continuer à produire autant de
déchets qu'on le fait il y a une
conscience collectif était nécessaire et
on doit faire changer les choses
[Musique]
forte analyse du besoin qui a été menée
en 2018 2019
l'objectif était de d'avoir un état des
lieux de départ par exemple on est passé
à une collecte par semaine en ordures
ménagères c'était déjà le cas dans trois
communes de l'agglo donc si ça marche
dans trois potentiellement on se dit que
ça peut marcher ailleurs cette analyse
du besoin nos ambassadeurs sont allés
regarder dans les poubelles
et le constat qu'avait été fait à
l'époque 2018 2019
c'est que non seulement tous les bacs
n'était pas forcément sorti à chaque
passage il ya des gens qui ont pas
besoin de sortir autant parce qu'on
n'est plus que deux dans le foyer qu'il
ya des gens publient donc ça veut dire
qu'on avait détourné kate et fait
systématiquement parfois pour la moitié
simplement du free sans parler d'une
méconnaissance du tri on y retrouve
beaucoup de papiers emballages
normalement il devrait être dans une
poubelle dédié où il ya un cycle de
revalorisation derrière on y retrouve
des textiles les textiles normalement on
a une centaine de bornes sur la ville où
on est censé collecter les tissus les
chaussures on y retrouve des métaux des
matériaux ça normalement effectivement
soit ça doit être à porter déchetterie
s'assoit soit ça doit être mis aux
encombrants presque la moitié de la
poubelle finalement ne devrait pas s'y
trouver un bon tri c'est d'abord des
déchets valorisés mais aussi moins de
collecte et une taxe revue à la baisse
les collectes pour les ordures ménagères
ont été réduites à une par semaine en
zone pavillonnaire à deux voire trois
dans les habitats collectifs
la collecte des emballages recyclables
une fois par semaine pour le vert un
passage par mois et une fois tous les
quinze jours pour les déchets verts
et pour les déchets qui ne rentrent pas
dans les bacs maison il ya le réseau des
déchetteries elles sont sept sur le
territoire ces derniers mois de nouveaux
services ion 2 jours
en 2020 plus de 210 mille passages ont
été effectués dans les sept déchetteries
du territoire habitants et
professionnels et ont déposé plus de
17000 800 tonnes de déchets les
déchetteries sont ouvertes 7 jours sur 7
avec toujours plus de services une fois
qu'on est à la déchetterie on trouve
tout un tas de possibilités
je serais tenté de dire qui a absolument
aucun flux qui ne trouve pas sa solution
on va trouver des solutions pour les
déchets dangereux et notamment les
solvants les peintures
voilà tout ça on peut la porter les
batteries on va trouver tout ce qu'on
appelle les d3e un tout petit matériel
électrique depuis 2010 est des bennes
dédiées aux déchets d' éléments
d'ameublement ont été déployés dans les
déchetteries un service attendu puisque
celle ci ne cesse de se remplir d'année
en année ces déchets sont ensuite
orientés vers des filières de recyclage
bois métaux piles ou encore huile de
vidange tout peut être rapportée en
déchetterie y compris les végétaux ceux
qui le souhaitent peuvent aussi retiré
du compost gratuitement sur
l'agglomération un plan compostage a été
mise en place depuis trois ans partant
du principe que dans nos poubelles
d'ordures ménagères il y avait une part
importante de ce qu'on appelle déchets
fermentescibles cela en théorie
effectivement on a la possibilité de les
valoriser individuellement chez soir
puis d'admir composteurs ont été
distribués par le territoire particulier
mais à l'échelle de l'agglo c'est pas si
énorme que ça donc ça veut dire que là
il faut encore que les gens sont motivés
n'hésitent pas à venir chercher un
composteur une formation de deux heures
est dispensée pour chaque personne
récupérant un composteur le compostage
ça marche bien quand on est en papillon
on a aussi développé toute une politique
de compostage pour le collectif
les composteurs sont disponibles
gratuitement dans les quartiers de
référence ont formé au compostage durant
une journée
si composteurs collectifs ou déjà été
installés d'ici deux ans des composteurs
électro mécaniques devraient être
installés dans les écoles de trappes et
villepreux pour récupérer les déchets
alimentaires des cantines dans le futur
écoquartier de la remise à voisins le
bretonneux un composteur identiques
devraient être implantés
pour limiter les déchets différents
acteurs se sont associés aux territoires
c'est le cas de la croix rouge qui
collectent zéro à l'horizon les
vêtements c'est aussi le cas des n'a eu
satrapes qui récupère toutes sortes de
dos et de la faune se recale de
l'énergie et du climat qui a lancé le
défi zéro déchet pour la gestion des
produits textiles et les chaussures le
territoire a signé une convention avec
la croix rouge
l'organisme récupère et revalorise les
tissus plus de 100 bornes ont pris place
sur la voie publique
l'été dernier durant cinq mois un
système de ressourcerie itinérante dans
les quartiers avaient aussi été impulsé
le but était d'aller à la rencontre des
habitants pour faciliter la démarche de
don et du réemploi
les dons et le réemploi c'est justement
le quotidien d'emmaüs attrape au sein du
mouvement créé par l'abbé pierre en 1949
tous ceux réutilise où se recycle rien
ne se jette on récupère les dons des
personnes sous plusieurs formes
[Musique]
on va aller chercher à domicile on nous
amène énormément pour nous donner des
meubles des vêtements des objets du
quotidien des
des lidd des meubles de en tous genres
mais aussi la vaisselle les jouets les
livres et tout objet de décoration
le tout trier dans les ateliers par les
compagnons en échange une somme modique
et demandé aux acheteurs en fonction de
l'état du produit ici prime la
solidarité selon l'état de l'objet
nous leur mettons nous valorisons et
nous leur mettons en vente directement
si l'état de l'objet n'est pas
satisfaisant il repart directement
vers le recyclage la seconde option
emmaüs a signé plusieurs conventions
avec diverses filières de recyclage
selon les types de matériaux bois
électronique tissus par exemple nous
avons un partenariat avec une petite
petite association qui s'appelle la
veste en jeans locale qui
qui nous demande à récupérer énormément
de jean par exemple pour refaire
des vêtements emmaüs a également un
partenariat avec le réseau de
déchetteries de saint quentin en
yvelines
pour toujours plus de recyclage et plus
de dons puisqu'en novembre 2020
un nouveau local emmaüs a ouvert à
plaisir certes recycler c'est bien mais
ne pas produire de déchets c'est mieux
nous nous sommes rendus à l' agence de
l'énergie et du climat qui a lancé en
2020 la 4e édition du défi zéro déchet
le défi 0 léger c'est un concours de
réduction de déchets on organise en
partenariat avec des collectivités de
territoire dessus des 6 flynn et des
associations également de territoires
qui sont sensibles à ces sujets
[Musique]
on accompagne les foyers intéressés à
leur apprendre comment réduire leurs
poubelles pour l'instant on a entre 15
et 20 associations partenaires c'est des
associations qui organisent des ateliers
tout au cours de défi apprendre à faire
des des produits ménages soit même des
recettes de cuisine anti gaspi
répercuter en fait le défi nous aider à
réduire les poubelles mais aussi nous
apprend à avoir d'autres façons de
consommer et de l'agir le défi zéro
déchet c'est possible quotidien avec
quelques petits efforts et en changeant
quelques habitudes qui vont perdurer
pour toujours valérie et sa fille chloé
habitants de guyancourt ont relevé le
défi
je suis très concerné par l'écologie
depuis longtemps
[Musique]
mais au niveau du du tri des déchets
c'est ça restait très basique et puis
j'avais j'avoue peu d'informations sur
le sujet mais j'avais envie de
progresser
j'étais curieuse encadrés par la lèque
et une dizaine d'associations des
environs valérie a participé aux
conférences visites et ateliers avant de
mettre en pratique il ya aucune
contrainte
on réalise on met en place les éco
gestes qui nous plaisent il ya des
choses très faciles à faire donc on a
des résultats spectaculaires très vite
donc là par exemple on va faire très
facilement une poudre lave vaisselle on
a besoin de ces trois que ces trois
produits qui peuvent resservir plusieurs
fois et elle perd carbonate de soude le
les cristaux de soude et l'acide
citrique et voilà on a mis nos trois
produits et on va juste secoué et voilà
là on a je ne sais combien de lavage
pour le lave vaisselle réalisé en
quelques secondes
et pour celles et ceux qui préfèrent la
formule pastilles compact placer la
poudre dans de petits moules et humecter
tout en laissant reposer une nuit dans
sa cuisine valérie hash est désormais en
vrac pour mettre fin à tout emballage
pour la conservation des aliments
elle a réalisé elle même des emballages
en cire d'abeille qui remplace le film
plastique
banny également les emballages aluminium
et autres essuie tout fini les
bouteilles d'eau en plastique qu'on boit
désormais l'eau du robinet côté salle de
bains dentifrice baume à lèvres maison
et cotons démaquillants lavables ont
remplacé les produits industriels et les
coteaux jetables sa fille chloé réalise
elle mène son déodorant legros constat
là la découverte
c'est qu'en plus de faire du bien à
l'environnement on se fait du bien à soi
même puisque on élimine pas mal de
produits toxiques en fait il ya du
toxique à peu près partout on fait
beaucoup d'économies donc c'est
bénéfique sur toute la ligne et on dit
mais pourquoi je n'ai pas fait plus tôt
on essaye de gâcher - on essaye de
simplifier la réduction des déchets dans
la poubelle passe aussi par le
compostage déchets verts ou alimentaires
fourniront le terreau pour le jardin
fort de l'application de ces bonnes
résolutions
valérie a pesé ces poubelles lors du
défi zéro déchet résultats donc moi par
exemple sur les ordures ménagères
j'avais -84% sans appel désormais la
poubelle d'ordures ménagères n'est sorti
qu'une fois par mois et la poubelle de
recyclables une fois tous les quinze
jours et au quotidien c'est plutôt
amusant
en fait c'est plutôt gratifiant et
motivant à chaque fois qu'on met en
place des choses on voit les résultats
et puis c'est aussi source des changes
famille voisins collègues tout le monde
profite désormais des astuces de valérie
sachet qui a réparé café a vu le jour à
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux à raison
d'une fois par mois
et puis n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site de
l'agglomération
si vous avez un doute sur le tri de vos
déchets enfin n'hésitez pas à vous
rapprocher d'une association c'est comme
valérie vous souhaitez limiter vos
déchets au quotidien
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]